adam paris les vestiges des
manifestations habite encore les
grillages entre ses murs quelques heures
après le retrait de kramer l'unique
repreneur certains salariés ne semble
pas surpris on s'y attendait de toute
façon vu les apports qu'il a demandée
pour racheter de toute façon on savait
pertinemment que s'enliser de l'état
sont les aides de tout le monde il n'y
arriverait pas et en plus il n'a pas pu
prouver que son projet était plus viable
que deux ans donc honnêtement pour moi
je pense que c'est mieux comme ça plutôt
que les gens restés pickeu se retrouve
deux ans après au chômage depuis
septembre c'est la division qui règne
entre les salariés
certains pour la reprise de leur usine
d'autres préférant le plan social une
pétition entre travailleurs avaient même
été lancé au sujet du repreneur kramer
un point de crispation entre les
employés en maintenant deux bretons 10e
menant les dans les roues à une
repreneur ça prend c'est le repreneur à
faire ce qu'ils veulent
bah moi j'ai signé en fait on a signé ce
n'était pas pour contre monsieur kramer
c'était par le choix de partir pour
cette déléguée syndicale si l'offre du
repreneur n'a pas tenu c'est à cause de
l'actuel propriétaire de jacob delafon
l'américain colère pour nous
colère à elle les utilise la politique
de la terre brûlée et pour nous ils sont
à l'origine de la pétition qui a eu avec
la complicité d'un ou quelques salariés
qui sont contre le repreneur
donc ça c'est pour nous c'est vraiment
quelque chose que nous avons beaucoup de
mal à encaisser les syndicats espèrent
encore une reprise des négociations
entre kramer et colère un souhait
partagé par le ministère de l'économie
pour sauver en partie les 144 emplois
menacés